[Music]
hello and welcome to
sophie ridge on sunday what will have
thought
a few months ago if we've been told that
in the week leading up to the largest
set of elections in years
politicians would be having an argument
about how posh john lewis is
but here we are with questions still
being asked about how the prime minister
funded the renovation of his downing
street flat
during the watergate scandal the central
question was what did the president know
and when did he know it with boris
johnson it's a question of what did the
prime minister owe
and when did he owe it but in many ways
the crucial political question is do
voters actually
care labour is hoping that they do the
conservatives have gambled
that they don't well on thursday we'll
find out who's made the smarter bet
in just a moment we'll be talking about
those allegations against the prime
minister and much more with the foreign
secretary dominic
raab his labour counterpart lisa nandy
will be joining us as her party tries to
make
accusations of sleaze stick we'll also
be talking to the former chair of the
public accounts committee day margaret
hodge
and with the scottish elections just
days away the leader of the lib dems and
scotland willie rennie
will be joining us plus this week we've
been investigating the
election race that's happening in wales
speaking to all the major
party leaders there but first the
government is today announcing plans
to allow people who come into contact
with someone with cover 19 to avoid
isolation by taking daily tests so let's
find out
a bit more about that the foreign
secretary dominic rabb joins us now from
westminster and just tell us a bit more
about these plans to
allow people to take daily tests rather
than isolate what's the idea
good morning sophie well we've made
great progress with the rollout of the
vaccine
over 34 million people have had their
first dose 60 percent of the population
and one of the things we're looking
towards are the next steps of the road
maps obviously the 17th of may is a
stepping stone and then
at the 21st of june and as part of the
process of easing out of
uh lock down we want to make sure that
and we're looking at it we're trialing
it and we're
uh obviously testing it very carefully
but whether the
the the current system of iso isolation
at home can be
if you like scale back and the way to do
that or one of the ways to do it and
again i just emphasize we're testing it
is to have these rapid tests so that you
take a one a day
and as long as you haven't got symptoms
that would allow you to avoid having to
do the isolation you'd otherwise need to
it's just one of the tools along with
the vaccine that we're
we're looking at very closely to make
sure that we take steps out of this lock
down back to normal
in a sure footed way is there a risk
about the reliability
of these rapid tests though the lateral
flow tests um
apparently they only identify around 58
of people who have covered without
symptoms
is that really good enough well that's
all the more reason that we're testing
it looking at it very carefully but
you'd have to take them daily
you would have to be without symptoms
and it's on top of all the other
measures so it's something that we're
looking at but of course as you can see
it's always a balance
we're not going to do anything that
would imperil the huge progress we've
made
in rolling out this vaccine keeping
people safe getting the economy back to
normal
you talk about the huge progress in
rolling out the vaccine the sunday times
is reporting that secondary school
pupils
could be offered the fisa vaccine as
soon as september is that something
under consideration
well i'm not going to speculate at um
what we're going to do beyond the
existing roadmap the key thing we're
focused on
right now and i know there's a lot of
speculation safe in the papers but the
key thing we focus
on right now is making sure that every
adult has the vaccine
i was offered the vaccine by the end of
july is it under consideration though
it will be a massive accomplishment but
it's also the point at which
uh and you'll have seen it from the road
map that almost all of the social
restrictions will be lifted
um but uh and i and i can't talk the
details of um
of the other trials because that's uh
not within my portfolio but you're right
that we're looking at all the different
contingencies to make sure
that the the easing up uh of the
restrictions that the returning to
normal
can be done in a safe and secure way
okay you're talking about of course the
success of the vaccine roll out and
those next steps going forward
almost 70 of people in of adults in
england
now have covered antibodies either
through prior infection or because
they've been vaccinated
but we're still not even allowed to give
our mums a hug if both of us have been
fully vaccinated
why not look there's all of the
risks that come with this that we just
got to gauge very carefully
uh on the 17th of may we'll take another
the third step in the roadmap if you
like
um we'll ease up there'll be more
opportunities for uh households to
mix inside subject to the the caveats on
that uh and then come
the 21st of june which is you know we're
already into
may uh we'll have almost all the social
restrictions
um that will be lifted so all i'd say to
people at this stage is i know that
people are hankering just
uh to go a bit faster but actually we've
i think uh i feel vindicated that taking
steady steps
out of the lockdown is the smart way to
go and then we can assess all the data
all the evidence that comes back and
make sure
that we're not unpicking the gains that
have been made so we're very close now
to really turning the corner and i and i
think we we still need to be careful
as we go um because i said uh we don't
want to see the gains lost and the
sacrifices that have been made
um uh are undone i mean you talk about
balancing risk
surely it's got to be quite low risk uh
to you know hug someone who's been
vaccinated
at a time when infections are so low and
of course every death is a tragedy
but there were seven deaths from covered
yesterday an estimated
450 people die of cancer every day
they're still not allowed to hug their
loved ones we're a risk of
prioritizing covid above all else right
now
well you've we've heard this debate over
the last year and we've always said it
every week but it's more
just to come it's not really a debate to
have over the last year is it i accept
that a time when
infection rates were very high when
deaths were high that was not the
debate to be having but right now when
there are seven covert deaths
recorded yesterday would 70 if adults in
england have antibodies
surely this is the time to be having the
debate and we are and we've had it for
the last year
and the question will be i mean the the
question you asked takes us straight
into vaccine certificates and all the
rest of that
she's been very contentious for various
reasons all i'd say is actually if you
take a look at the big picture
by the time we get to the 21st of june
almost all social
restrictions will be lifted so there's
only a little bit more time to go
but it's right to make sure we do it in
a careful way um and i think the public
support that they've supported
uh the approach by and large but i think
for their great credit
um and we're at the end really of the
process if you like we've got two more
steps to
to take but i do think given the the
roll out of the vaccine that's exciting
it's got people thinking about
not just the social interaction but yeah
of course things like hugging your loved
ones that you haven't been able to do
for a while but i do think we just
need to make sure that in the last lap
if you like that we're careful
and we don't lose the gains that we've
made you talk about almost all
restrictions
being lifted in the months ahead what
exactly do you mean by that what
restrictions are going to be here
well if you look at the roadmap it's set
up very clearly we get
may the 17th there's going to be subject
to the evidence
and and the way we set out is no earlier
than the 17th of may we'll look again at
the
travel restrictions so that's something
that's going to be set
out uh well before then uh there'll be
the opportunity for households to
households to mix
um uh indoors then when we get to june
uh there's a whole range of other
lifting of restrictions and and the
roadmap sets out that the
most if not all of the social
restrictions will at that point again
subject to the evidence be lifted
so the point i'm making is and of course
we'll we'll we'll set out what other
um uh conditions and caveats and
safeguards
still need to be in place based on the
evidence as we go but the point i'm i'm
making is actually that 21st of june
uh fourth step out of lockdown is is not
far away now so
i think if we just hang on keep being
guided by the science and the evidence
measure the progress we're making
carefully we're nearly there
we've seen some pretty harrowing scenes
from india a country which really is
still grappling
with their kovid 19 pandemic is the uk
doing enough to help
yes and i spoke to recently spoke to
foreign minister jaishankar
my opposite number there we've said that
we'll do whatever uh
we we can um whatever they asked for i
do think it's important with these
emergency uh packages you listen very
carefully to the the
indian authorities and see that we're
giving them what they they need and want
so we've given them oxygen concentrators
we've given them
um ventilators we're going to be sending
out another package of thousand
ventilators
um very shortly we've also looked at
these uh oxygen generators like mini
factories
and that's the thing they need right now
um and i've been in regular contact with
from minister jai shankar i'll be seeing
him
uh tomorrow as well and we're doing
everything that our indian friends need
uh in their hour of need i just want to
move on to
talk about the funding of boris
johnson's
flat renovation a story that of course
has been bubbling
for a little while now and the sunday
times has been told that there was a
second
invoice for the work that was paid
directly
settled directly with the supply by a
third party believed to be a donor
is that true well sophie as the
prime minister set out this week he
covered the cost himself
he's followed all the relevant codes of
conduct at all relevant times he took
official advice
all along the way there are there are
three reviews now i think
into this and i think the right thing
for me to do is not add political
commentary that could otherwise
prejudice those
reviews but to respect the integrity of
them so i'm not going to offer you i'm
afraid
any more uh commentary or or if you like
chatter on the various different reports
and speculation that i've seen in the
sunday papers
i'm not asking you for commentary or
about speculation i'm just asking for
clear answers
to questions yes and i think the prime
minister's been very clear
and we've got for for any questions that
regarded as uh
uh not yet answered there are three
reviews uh the prime ministers and
set up some of them is engaging fully
with all of them and i think the right
thing to do is to respect
the integrity of them let them run their
course and they'll resolve any
outstanding questions people have
oh right the premise has been very clear
i must have missed this
because i believe the key question is
who initially paid for the refurbishment
of the flat so has it been clear in
answering that i think as i said i can
go back over what i said to you before
um sophie but the pm's been very clear
covered the cost himself
he's followed all the codes of conduct
he's taken official advice
um and frankly i i don't know the uh any
of the other details of it and there are
three reviews that will
uh look into those questions and the
prime minister and the government of
course and
uh embrace the transparency and the
integrity of those processes
okay you're talking about the
transparency and the integrity of the
processes
the reviews that are going on and one of
them is being carried out by christopher
guy the new advisor on ministerial
standards so who has the power to decide
whether the conclusions of that
investigation are published and acted on
well we've i think the prime minister's
been clear that we will
have full transparency in relation to
the processes um
and not quite the question i ask though
is it well so
look that process is something that's
been in place um
for successive governments uh he's going
to engage fully with it
and there'll be transparency uh around
the conclusion today
what's the answer then if you're being
clear and transparent what's the answer
to the question so sorry
i thought i'd answered it what's the
specific question you think i've
overlooked sophie
who has the power to decide whether the
conclusions of the investigation being
carried out by chris
the guide are published and acted on
well in terms of
um the publication that the prime
minister has already been cleared that
the
there's going to be full transparency if
you're asking uh
who has the uh ultimate accountability
over the prime minister it's the
electorate and the voters um that's the
way it works
so much for explaining how you know the
electoral system works in the uk i
really appreciate that
i'm just asking who has the power to
decide whether the conclusions of that
investigation are acted on the answer is
the prime minister isn't it
well the prime minister is the ultimate
arbiter of
or the ultimate accountability for the
ministerial code
uh he has the authority to dismiss
ministers to make sure they live up to
the code and so if your question's then
but who holds him to account
ultimately and that's why i come back to
the point i made earlier there's no um
separate uh body or individual that will
have power over him he's the british
people he's accountable to them that's
why we have elections
but when it comes to this investigation
yeah the prime minister is effectively
judge jury and executioner for his own
trial
no because he's uh as i said he's going
to be fully transparent about it he'll
be accountable to parliament
uh which is of course the main way the
government the day is held to account
and then ultimately the ballot boxes the
way it works
okay um let's just try and ask about
another a claim that's in the sunday
times i've got a feeling i know what the
answer to this one's going to be as well
and but the sunday times
has also been told that the prime
minister asked a conservative party
donor to pay for his child care costs is
that true
i've got no idea you think i have
conversations like that with the prime
minister
um i i can't comment on every uh
little bit of gossip that's in the
newspapers sophie i've had a pretty
full schedule this week and next week
with the g7 i've been out at the un
cyprus talks i've been talking to the
u.n secretary general so forgive me if i
don't
uh know all the ins and outs of uh the
prime minister's private life and i
wouldn't comment on them even if i did
it's not the prime minister's private
life though is it it's not just gossip
the electoral commission is
investigating whether the law has been
broken
exactly so uh and and i think the right
thing it's not gossip
i think it i think but the last thing
you uh asked me about i think is
uh an example of title tattle but look
i'm not doubting that there are
important issues at stake which is why
the electoral commission review should
be allowed to run its course and i don't
think the right thing for me to do
is say anything that could prejudice or
is political commentary on that
is 157 000 pounds a year a decent salary
yes of course it is and uh if you're
referring to i mean that
is referring to what um cabinet members
of the prime minister and of course we
know when we
when we go into public service um
we do it as a matter of honor and uh
it's a great privilege to be able to do
these roles in these jobs in government
and of course sophie you'll know that
we've been freezing ministerial salaries
for many years now we've taken that
decision
because of the financial climate that
we're in and we do these jobs because
we're committed to public service
you're talking about the important
issues that you've been involved in of
course we know that there are so many
important issues
going on at the minute with a pandemic
and elsewhere if that is the case
why is the prime minister spending his
time phoning newspaper editors to
criticize dominic cummings no again
you're asking me to
comment or verify the speculation in the
in the newspapers but
um the the prime minister is i i know
because i saw him
last week absolutely focused on the job
of
getting us through the pandemic and
wants to get back to the leveling up
agenda making sure all parts of the uk
are prospering and we've got the
investment we need and we've got this
exciting year of global leadership with
the g7 presidency and the foreign
ministers
who will be welcoming to london next
week so we're looking at all of those
issues and that's where the prime
minister is focusing his time his
efforts
and his energy so this is genuinely what
i don't understand about this
is that with all the things that you're
listing there that the government needs
to try
and focus on all the things that are
important issues for the electorate
and the government as well why don't you
just shut this story down why do you
have all these investigations why is the
cabinet secretary spending his time
trying to work out what happened um you
know when you could just answer the
questions
who paid for the original loan i just
don't understand why you're just not
forthcoming with the answers
i think i think the prime minister has
been crystal clear about it i can repeat
the answers that i've given to you
but i do think if you've got those
reviews underway the right things you
set them up
in order to answer precisely the
questions sophie you're asking me i
think it's the right thing to do to let
them run their course
and not to try and prejudice them with
political commentary it's fine for jones
to do it
and the papers but i don't think it's
right for a cabinet member to do that
do you really think the prime minister
has been crystal clear yeah i do and i
think
you know i've been out campaigning the
local elections as well as all the stuff
i'm doing as foreign secretary i
genuinely no one has asked me about this
okay
um fine well let's move on let's move on
uh you're hosting an in-person meeting
of foreign ministers this week and
you're going to be talking about
improving girls education you're going
to be talking about reducing poverty
incredibly important things of course
but you're also cutting the uk's aid
spending by
four billion pounds so are you just
replacing hard cash with one words here
no i don't think so look you're right to
say we've had to take this extremely
difficult decision to reduce
and find savings in the aid budget and
that's because of the impact that covert
has had the biggest
contraction we've seen in the economy in
300 years a budget deficit
uh double what we saw at the peak of the
financial crisis in 2008 nine
but let's face it we're still let's be
honest about it be clear about it we're
still getting
10 billion pounds of aid
this year we're the largest contributor
to gavi
the global vaccine alliance with the
third biggest
g7 aid donor measured as a proportion of
gdp
uh on everything from climate finance
where we're doubling our contribution to
girls education
where we're leading this charge to get
40 million more girls 12
years of quality education we have an
enormous impact
um and we as i said we're still not
withstanding the savings i've been
very honest and transparent about we're
still one of the the leading
um aid spenders in the world but one
thing we're also doing and that's why
we're proud to host the g7 presidency is
we're using uh the example we set the
leadership we provide
and our convening power to get other
countries uh to
to step up in what is a team effort
whether it's the the challenge of
shifting the dial on climate change or
girls education
or indeed getting the very poorest
countries access to the vaccine and
that's what global britain's all about
being a force for good in the world
i understand of course the financial
pressures that every government has to
grapple with but can you guarantee that
these cuts to aid
have been made to make try and make sure
that they
minimize the harm on the poorest people
so first of all i don't think people do
really realise
certainly some of the commentary doesn't
doesn't take full count of just how much
damage the
covid has done to the public finances
and that's why i gave the
figures i did earlier but the way we've
approached this first of all as i said
we've got 10 billion pounds
huge amount still what the third biggest
g7 donor and what i did at the start of
the process is set
seven priorities from uh climate finance
and climate change
through to humanitarian
support and relief and made sure rather
than salami slicing budgets according to
i don't know
10 15 whatever percent we actually said
no we're going to really focus on
driving
and getting the very most out of the 10
billion pounds that taxpayers in the
public funding
uh is going into and the reason we
wanted to do that is to have a more
strategic
approach and also to get maximum value
out of every penny of taxpayers money
that goes abroad and that's the approach
we've taken
talk about maximum value out of
taxpayers money uh the un population
fund which supports
family planning so the uk is cutting 85
percent
of its support this year unicef says
it's seeing a 60
drop in core funding and they say the
cuts are falling on the shoulders
of the world's children are you
comfortable with that
look i i found the the process of making
those savings very difficult but of
course
that you'd expect that what i'd say in
relation to
public health is we're still putting in
uh 1.3 billion pounds
into global public health initiatives
next year over five years we're putting
1.6
billion into gavi the global vaccine
alliance
obviously our public health spending has
been shifted
and focused on the pandemic and on
everything from the billion doses that
we've secured
for the poorest countries around the
world to the fact that we invested in
the r d that produced the
astrazeneca vaccine which is now uh
helping so many countries come through
the pandemic
i think we've had an incredible impact
and i i can tell you when i speak to dr
ted ross at the world
health organization or the un secretary
general i spoke to both of them in
person this week
they've got nothing but praise for the
huge impact and the leadership that
we're taking
the g7 this week the foreign minister's
meeting is a great opportunity not just
to lead by example
but to use our convenient power and make
it a real team effort
to tackle these problems together okay
dominic rob thank you very much for
coming on the program this morning thank
you
dominic rob there well let's get some
reaction to that interview we can speak
now to
labour's shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy uh who joins us
from salford morning um so the
government's announcing plans to allow
people who come into contact with
someone who's tested positive covert 19
to take a daily test rather than
self-isolate is that something that
labour backs
i think we're certainly very keen to see
it made easier for people to go about
their normal lives particularly because
we've long had concerns
about how the economic impact of of
quarantine
arrangements on people because the
government hasn't been quick to come
forward with financial support
so i think i think it's very welcome
that that we're exploring
ways in which we can make it easier for
people to get back to normal
more quickly but obviously as always
with this we want to follow the science
we want to make sure that it's robust
we meet regularly with the sage
scientists and it's something that we'll
certainly be asking them
questions about next time we meet the
issue is i guess the
reliability of these lateral flow tests
uh is there a concern that they're just
not good enough at picking up
asymptomatic heavy uh cases well
there have been concerns raised by some
scientists the
there's a growing body of evidence um
around them
and that's one of the things that we one
of the reasons why we meet regularly
with the sage scientists is because
we want to make sure that they are
robust that we're not
taking measures to unlock that people
desperately want to see that people
desperately need
that will unravel the amazing progress
that has been made through the national
vaccination
effort over the last few months there's
light at the end of the tunnel i think
we can all feel it we can see it
but we're not there yet and so we've
just got to take these things carefully
it's right to do tests it's right to do
trials before
we pilot them i think largely speaking
we are with the government on this we
want to unlock
we want to get back to whatever normal
looks like on the other side of this
but what we don't want to do is to
unravel the progress that we've made in
the last few months
talking about the success of the vaccine
rollout sunday times reporting today
that the fisa
vaccine could be rolled out to secondary
school pupils from september is that
something that labour would support
the the the the view that's been given
to us by
uh the scientists that we meet with
chris whitty patrick valance
and others is that there is some
evidence around
transmission rates amongst secondary
school students so it may be
beneficial obviously this is a
fast-moving
scenario the evidence is massing all the
time
but it certainly would make sense to us
if if the scientists believe that this
is beneficial it would make sense
to us to offer it to secondary school
pupils over the course of this pandemic
we've seen
some measures taken particularly in
secondary schools to try to keep
people safe and to keep teachers safe
and teaching staff
as well and i think the approach that
has been taken by most schools is one
that we very much support which is about
supporting
parents and young people to be able to
make good decisions rather than
you know tough enforcement measures
making people comply with regulations
we've been told all the way along by
public health officials that doesn't
work in terms of public health you have
to
work with people in order to to advance
public health not
um you know it's the it's the carrot not
the stick
okay um i'm keen to move on to talk
about the uh recent row
over the renovations of boris johnson's
flat we were speaking about it with
dominic rob who said the prime
minister's been crystal clear there's
reviews going on
now it'd be wrong for them to comment
any further
now the electoral commission is
investigating whether offenses have
occurred
over the funding of that redecoration
if it finds that offences have occurred
should the prime minister
resign well i i think that the we don't
need an electoral commission
um inquiry to know that the prime
minister is withholding information
from the public that rightly belongs in
the public domain
it's appalling that we're in a situation
where he won't come clean
about who loaned him money or gave him
money
and what favors or promises may have
been given
in return we already know that this is a
prime minister who frankly thinks that
the rules don't apply to him
and his friends he's quite happy for his
cabinet ministers to break the
ministerial code
and then not resign he's quite happy for
his adviser to drive around the country
with covid in the middle of lockdown and
not resign
and i think people are angry actually
that in a year when we've all followed
the rules
often at great personal cost not saying
goodbye to loved ones in care homes not
attending funerals
of people who've died we've followed the
rules because we know that the rules
matter
and yet over and over again we've seen a
prime minister who thinks that the rules
frankly don't
apply to him it's appalling is it really
fair to talk about
people not being able to attend funerals
because of covert and somehow equate
that to
boris johnson and how he funds the
redecoration the flat particularly when
he says that he did actually end up
paying for it
it is absolutely fair because he is a
pattern of behavior
from this prime minister that we don't
need inquiries to evidence he evidences
it
himself every single day when he refuses
to tell the truth when he refuses to
come
clean there is an arrogance at the heart
of this that's
that that he seems to believe that we
don't deserve to know the truth
about what goes on in government this
really matters because
at the moment we don't know who the
prime minister is beholden to
we don't know if he's promised them
anything in return we don't know what
the implications of that
are and over the last few weeks we've
seen this raft of
revelations about the financial networks
at the heart of government
cabinet ministers who profited from the
pandemic favors that have been done
for for donors from the tory party
we've seen foreign dictators who are
able to pick up the phone to the prime
minister
and give instructions and instead of
pushing back on those instructions
he puts one of his top advisors onto the
case
if if the prime minister is beholden to
other people
who is he not serving and that's the
people of this country and that's why
this really matters this is about
integrity
it's about trust and it's about whether
there's one rule for them and one rule
for everybody else and i feel that
particularly
strongly at the moment with the year
that we've had i think
other people in this country feel
particularly strongly about it as well
it's just simply not good enough
we'll find out how people do feel on
thursday of course so in the
local elections and just one more
question on the um
allegations around the prime minister
there were reports in the sunday times
that at least
one conservative donor was approached
about paying the bill for the prime
minister's child's care now number 10
has said that the prime minister paid
the cost
they don't seem to have confirmed
whether he paid the original bill
dominic raab
earlier said that this was just gossip
what do you make of it
i just think you know if the back of 11
years of huge
cuts to public services and to austerity
when ordinary families in this country
have seen their income squeezed and have
struggled to pay their
child care costs themselves it is
extraordinary that we've got a prime
minister who is going around
saying he can't possibly afford to pay
his hope for his own child care costs
at a time when he earns he's in the top
1
of earners in this country and over and
over again that's the pattern that we've
seen one rule for them
one rule for everybody else whether it's
um saying that he can't afford to pay
to have his flat redecorated at a time
when they're denying leaseholders
the the financial help that they need in
order to make their flats safe
after the grenfell tragedy it's just one
rule for them one rule for everybody
else that's what's so distasteful about
all of this
um important of course to say of course
uh that number turner is saying that the
prime minister's pay the cost of the
child care
and the flat renovation no one's
profited from any of the
contracts as well um now despite all the
noise that labour
has made about this the fact that you
say that people
are really bothered that it seems to be
in your view one rule for
boris johnson one rule for anyone else
labour is still
behind in the polls i accept that things
seem to have narrowed slightly
in the last 24 hours but you haven't
been in a lead in a major poll
since january given the local elections
are just a few days away are you a bit
worried
i'm not worried but i'm not complacent
i've never
taken votes for granted you know when i
was first elected in wigan
lots of people said to me well this is a
labour seat i don't believe in labour
seats or tory seats
people in in the across this country
make up their own minds in elections and
we've seen that with big seismic shifts
over recent years we're going out we're
fighting for every vote we're not taking
a single one for granted
to be honest with you sophie i have felt
in the last few weeks that something is
shifting
a little it doesn't feel like 2019
which was the worst election i i can
ever remember fighting
in my lifetime i think people have
understood that labour is under new
management
and they're looking at us again i think
they are really concerned
about the way that this prime minister
carries on and the way in which it seems
to be one rule for them and one rule for
everybody else
so i think people are starting to think
again about labor
whether that translates into to good
results at these local elections i'm not
sure
to be honest we've got a big mountain to
climb and
uh with it's going to take time to
rebuild that trust but we're going out
we're fighting for every single vote
and whether or not we get a good set of
results in these local elections i think
they're likely to still be very
difficult for us and we're determined to
regain that trust this is personal for
me
you know lots of my constituents in
wigan have felt for a long time that
labour has been moving away from them
and i am absolutely determined that i'm
going to prove to them that that is not
the case that labour is coming home to
them
i can't help but thinking listening to
you that it feels like a bit of a low
bar
you're saying that it doesn't feel quite
as bad as 2019 which is the worst
election you can ever
remember from labour you know you're
talking about
we're in a situation where if labour
holds onto hartlepool a seat that you've
always held since it was created
in the face of the conservatives who've
been in power for 11 years and that
would be seen as
a success i mean how low is the bar well
i think the bar was
became pretty low in december 2019 when
we had our worst election results in 100
years and we saw our base collapse in
every nation region of the uk
but we're we're not unambitious for what
comes next and i think the tories
shouldn't take votes for granted we
people are looking at us again we are
starting to make progress you know got a
new leader in scotland
and asawa who's making a real really
good impact with the electorate people
can see
that he's absolutely determined to put
the future of scotland
right at the center of the debate in
scotland not just these divisive
questions that the smp wants to go back
to
so i i don't think that's a low bar i
think that's a level of ambition for
this country we won't be satisfied
until we've won people's trust we're in
power in towns and cities across the
country
and in westminster and we can start
actually delivering for people
again after a lost decade but that means
that we have to go out and fight for
every vote that's
you know don't read that from me as as a
lack of ambition
for this country it's just a recognition
that we've got a lot of work to do and
we're determined to do it
i'm keen to move on to your uh brief as
well
uh dominic raj was talking about the
cuts to international aid talking about
difficult decisions but they have to be
made in the face
of the economic crisis and you know
we're still spending 10 billion pounds
on international aid this year
is it right that we are scaling back
scandal spending
well the the problem is twofold one is
that with
scaling back uh spending that was
uh in the middle of a pandemic and that
is extraordinarily
short-sighted it's one of the greatest
assets that the united kingdom has
around the world
we're highly respected in terms of of
age
and it gives us soft power and influence
around the world as well which is
something we need very much with the
you know rising tensions between china
and the u.s
the aggression from russia the situation
in iran and other
other things but it's also that what is
being cut
is just appalling i mean in the middle
of a pandemic to cut health care
programs
to cut scientific research
just i just think it's it's unbelievably
short-sighted because in the end the
only way that the
the world comes through this is by
erasing
the virus everywhere in order to erase
it
anywhere and the uk has taken the acts
to programmes that helps us to do that
at the very moment that they have been
most needed so it's a really
short-sighted decision it doesn't make
any sense and it absolutely undermines
our moral authority on a world stage
we're also seeing this appalling
situation in india
uh when it comes to clover 19 um really
troubling
to see some of these sort of stories
coming out there
are we doing enough to try and provide
assistance
i think we can and should do more um the
uk has sent
a small two i think two now small
shipments of
um of assistance to india but don't
forget it was india that stepped up for
us when we were
almost a year ago today in really dire
straits struggling to contain the impact
of the pandemic the prime minister had
just left hospital
we were woefully unprepared and we had
to appeal to the rest
of the world for help and india stepped
forward to prove the export
of huge amounts of paracetamol to the uk
because we're in danger
of running out so there are long and
deep ties between us and india that mean
that we should step up
and provide more equipment more support
we are world leaders
in genomic sequencing we can track and
map
how this virus is mutating and
developing
only a few months ago matt hancock said
we should make that capacity available
to the world
we should be offering that support to
india at the moment given that we've
seen new variants emerging
that are causing real problems for them
and it ultimately will cause real
problems for us unless we understand
what's happening
and stop them in their tracks okay yeah
really important
situation in india developing of course
and just finally while i've got you on
something
slightly different um caitlyn jenner
who's running to be the governor of
california and former olympic medalist
who's also a transgender
has said that trans athletes who are
born male shouldn't be able to
compete in girls sports teams do you
agree with that
i've always thought this is something
that sports governing bodies need to
determine
they need to work across the industry
and with stakeholders in order to
determine
the rules for their own sports there are
lots of grey areas
in sporting competitions that that need
to be clarified and need to be dealt
with and i don't think it's for
politicians
okay fair enough um thank you very much
uh lisa and andy there
oh i think we have actually lost listen
andy uh unfortunately um but we did just
about get to the
end of the interview there uh now we've
been talking a bit about the uh local
elections already on the programme
and now on thursday voters across the uk
will go to the polls
and because the votes postponed from
last year is going to be the biggest set
of elections in the uk since 1973.
now arguably the biggest battle is in
scotland where voters will determine the
makeup
of the next scottish parliament
parliament but throughout the campaign
we've interviewed all of the major party
leaders and today we're going to be
completing the set with the leader
of the scottish lib dems woody rennie
who joins us now from
edinburgh thank you very much for being
with us so
the election's just a few days away
what's your pitch
liberal democrats want to put recovery
first not independence that means
cutting weights for mental health
treatment it means bounce back support
for children in schools it means
creating jobs for people
desperate for work and of course taking
action on the climate
in order to do that we need to bring the
country together we need to unite the
country because we'll need
the skills and talents of everyone to
get over these
massive challenges we shouldn't be
adding to the problems that we've
already got and the mountains we've all
got already got to climb
by adding independence into the mix
that will make it even more difficult to
get through this most deadly pandemic
where thousands of people
have died and thousands more have lost
their jobs so let's come together let's
put recovery first
and it's the liberal democrat seats in
this election that will make the
difference
between the parliament being focused on
recovery which liberal democrats want
and the parliament being focused on
independence which is what the snp want
so if you want to put recovery first
vote lib them
at the same time though you i'm sure
will accept that's been a
pretty difficult few years for the
liberal democrats if you really want to
have the influence that you're talking
about
what would be a good night well we're
getting
more people coming to us from all sorts
of different backgrounds who are going
to vote for us this time
in particular people who voted snp and
for independence before
because they recognize that it just
seems the wrong time
to focus on another independence
referendum in the wake of one of the
most deadly pandemics
and they are voting for the liberals the
question was
what would be a good night for you well
what would be a good night for us well
i'd never put any limits on the number
um of seats that we're going for i just
know we're going to
grow with the number of seats that we're
going to to gain in every part of
scotland
because the beauty of this election
sophie is that every single vote on the
peach ballot paper because remember we
have two votes in scotland
every single vote counts so if you want
to put recovery first then you need to
vote for the liberal democrats in every
corner of scotland and that means that i
know we're going to gain more seats
put recovery first not the time for
independence that message
definitely coming across now you said
recently that you would vote
against another referendum on
independence at every
opportunity but if the snp do win a
majority
how is it democratic to resist that well
it's very democratic that i follow what
my voters tell me to do
i mean i'm against another independence
referendum because i think it will
distract the country at a time
they need to build recovery if people
vote for me on the basis that i'm clear
crystal clear in an election campaign it
would be bizarre if i did the opposite
after the election but i don't accept
the premise of your question anyway
because all the polls are showing that
there's a decline in support for
independence and for the snp
because people know now is not the
moment to choose another
independence referendum when we've got
so many challenges
to overcome i mean we've got a mountain
of mental health weights in this country
sophie over 1500 people way over a year
young people wait over a year
to get mental health treatment that's 5
000 adults way over a year we've got one
of the highest
drug death rates in europe three and a
half times what it is
in england we need to focus on these
challenges to try and get recovery
to improve ordinary people's lives we
won't get that with another independence
referendum and that's why i will not
support it
under any circumstances at any time you
say you'll not support a
independent referendum under any
circumstances even if there is a
majority for it
you know the lib dem spent years
campaigning against the
brexit referendum result i mean is it
time to drop democrats from your name
i mean what we are saying is for the
next five years we need to put recovery
first that equally applies
to the issue of europe of course nobody
will be surprised that you know i'm a
very strong pro-european i was against
brexit i don't think it's good for the
country
but i recognize even i recognize that
the recovery has got to come first for
the next five years
that means putting aside the
independence issue and of course making
sure
that we smooth the relationship with
europe we make sure we can break down
the trade barriers
but now is the time to focus on the
recovery
not on the constitutional issues if it's
so important to focus on the recovery
rather than
independence why did you reject the
offer of the conservative party
to form a pro-union alliance well the
conservatives are part of the
problem in scotland and they brought us
brexit in the middle of our pandemic
we've seen all the the conservative
party is mired
in sleaze at westminster now what we
need is a progressive alternative in
scotland
a party that's going to stand up to put
recovery first a moderate centre-ground
center-left party
like the liberal democrats that will
focus on public services on improving
people's lives
not carrying on all the arguments about
independence
over and over again because that's what
the conservative party want
as much as the snp so if you want to put
all those divisions behind us
then you need to vote liberal democrat
in every part of scotland
i know it's coming across pretty clearly
your views about the conservative party
uh but at the same time if there was
going to be an independence referendum
would you
be prepared to hold your nose and focus
on a single cross-party campaign
i mean for goodness sake i mean we're
we're jumping several steps ahead here i
don't accept
that the snp or the nationalists will
get a majority because i think people
are going to
reject um the snp and their proposal for
another independence referendum
the idea that we'll immediately enter
another campaign just fills me with
dreads so i'm not even thinking about
that stuff
i want to focus on the recovery because
that will be the way to improve
people's lives today okay willie rene
thank you very much for being on the
show much appreciated
we were just talking about the elections
that are happening in scotland and wales
also has a crucial vote coming up on
thursday when voters will choose
members for the next welsh parliament
and with several parties battling it out
it's quite unclear who's going to form
the next government or even if the
numbers will allow one to be formed at
all
well this week the team's been on the
road to look at this intriguing contest
the last time people in wales voted for
their devolved parliament
david cameron was prime minister brexit
hadn't happened
and covered 19 didn't even exist
since 2016 it's fair to say a lot has
changed
but will that be reflected in next
thursday's elections
in the 22 years since the first meeting
of the welsh parliament
labour has always been in power here
although not necessarily with a majority
first minister mark drakeford is keen to
capitalise on his record dealing with
the pandemic
but some say that labour's approach in
this campaign has been too modest
well i think we belong in the middle
because that is where the great bulk
of opinion rests in wales the
conservative party in wales does not
believe in wales
it believes in handing wales back to
westminster
montgomery doesn't believe in the united
kingdom it would sever
us from our friends our relations our
fellow workers elsewhere in the uk
it is only the labour party that
believes in a
strong wales in a successful united
kingdom
and far from falling through the cracks
actually that represents
the great bulk of opinion here in wales
in the last four years the conservatives
have gained ground in wales
in the 2019 general election they won
six welsh seats off labour
now labour needs to win back some of
those votes just to maintain their
current standing in the welsh parliament
i think to match our result in 2016
would be a fantastic result for labour
as i said we started the campaign with
opinion polls telling us that labour
would win only 22 seats
to match our 2016. election result
particularly in the current
circumstances i think would be a very
high water mark for us
because uk parliamentary seats in wales
share the same boundaries with those in
the welsh parliament
comparisons between voting patterns are
possible
in the 2016 welsh assembly election
labour held a decisive lead
over the conservatives with 27 seats to
the conservative six
implied comrays six but fast forward
to the 2019 general election and the
conservatives surged
to 14 seats with labour losing out
labour are still expected to make a
stronger showing than the conservatives
this time
the latest voting forecasts have them a
good distance ahead
but not enough for a majority because of
the gains they made in 2019
the conservatives should be improving on
their 2016 result
anything less would be a failure we're
fighting every constituency in every
regional ballot
uh we're getting a very good response
indeed it's all about building on 2019 i
accept that and that's why
our strong economic road map out to the
covid crisis is an important part of our
platform
although the polls show people in wales
think highly of first minister mark
drakeford's handling of the pandemic
andrew davies says there isn't much to
celebrate
let's not forget that wales has the
highest death rate of any part of the
united kingdom regrettably that's hardly
labour and the welshfort labor first
minister keeping wales safe
let's also remember through the strength
of the union of the united kingdom
six billion pounds of money has come
into wales to support the fight against
the covid crisis
don't forget pride and labor would have
had as part of the european medicines
agencies which would have had us in the
european vaccination program
rather than actually this successful uk
vaccination program that is opening up
the economy
on all the big questions they have taken
the wrong choices
but this election is a three horse race
club camry may hold the balance of power
hoping to capitalise on a small growth
and support for welsh independence
support is uh increasing indeed
according to some important polls now
even a majority of labour voters
support independence and support for
independence in wales now is
higher than it was in scotland ten years
ago and of course
only a few years later they came within
five percent of winning an independence
referendum and politics is all about
momentum and the momentum is with
the independence movement black have
worked together in the past
could another coalition be on the cards
we're not prepared to concede
uh any other possibility than then
surging support not just for the
independence movement but for play
country if
young people in particular are
supporting independence
and play country unprecedented numbers
if they turn out to vote
uh then i think that we are we are
looking at the possibility of a historic
uh result
for black camry and for wales in this
election that's the prize i'm keeping my
eye
on that prize every bit of my energy is
focused on that
plight clearly didn't want to talk about
possible coalitions just yet
but they might have too soon we've
worked with other parties
in the senate throughout the history of
devolution the current government that's
just ending
had a liberal democrat minister and a
minister who is an independent member
of the senate we've always worked across
party lines
where other progressive parties can
agree on a programme for government
and that's always been the way i
approach it i am not interested
at all in political fixes
if we need to work with other parties
let's see if we can have a progressive
programme for a progressive nation this
is an election full of uncertainty with
seven ukip seats up for grabs
and 16 and 17 year olds voting for the
first time in wales
and if the result is inconclusive which
it may well be
that uncertainty could continue for some
time after as well
my piece on the welsh election there a
reminder that you can follow all the
results as they come in
on sky news it's a long process
different parts of the uk are going to
be declaring on friday and into the
weekend but it should be a really
fascinating story you don't want to miss
any of it
with us on tv or online now we were
talking earlier about the allegations
about boris johnson and the
refurbishment of his flat so we can talk
a bit more about this and some of the
wider issues that it raises
with the former chair of the public
accounts committee day margaret hodge
thank you very much for being with us
um taxpayers money hasn't been spent on
the flats
boris johnson settled the bill why
should we why should we care
because when we become members of
parliament we all sign
up to a set of standards we promise to
be open
we promise to be honest and we promise
to be accountable
and in uh telling us about the downing
street flat
boris johnson has failed all those tests
he's been neither open
honest or accountable and all the
uh inquiries that are currently taking
place on this issue
they don't go to the heart of the matter
so the electoral commission is looking
at the conservative party
his own advisor we know is toothless he
can't
initiate inquiries and we know that
boris johnson can ignore the findings
as he did with pretty patel so i think
it's really important
to have an inquiry into boris johnson's
own actions
and this is because it's part of a
patent sophie it doesn't stand on its
own
it stands with the dodgy contracts it
stands with the
uh appointments that have been made it
stands with the
the greens hill scandal it stands with
the whole dyson
effort and all this has become a part of
a pattern and we
just have got to have confidence in
those who are leading us
particularly in these troubled times
what exactly do you think
the prime minister could be guilty of
here and is it a resigning matter
what sorry i missed that philosophy what
can he be guilty of
yeah what do you think he could be
guilty of hearing is it a resigning
matter
well we'll have to wait and see i mean
to be honest
i think you know there's so much going
on at the moment it's outrageous that
we're having to spend
time on this we ought to be getting on
with the issues that are confronting
britain
like dealing with getting people back
into work or like dealing with the
social
care system which is so broken instead
we're having to focus on this
i don't know what govaris johnson is
guilty of i do know
that he has got uh form on this when um
i didn't inquiry into his actions when
he was mayor of london
uh at the garden bridge and what came
out of that
was a lack of honesty again uh
attendance you know he gave contracts to
friends and he didn't go through the due
process there and he wasted uh
ratepayers money and that
instance 46 million so he's gone that's
the point isn't it because you're
talking about taxpayers money there
which is quite different to
what is happening here and actually if
you're looking at taxpayers money then
you know boris johnson isn't the only
person to do up the number 11 flat tony
blair who you saved under
spent 285 000 in his decade as prime
minister but was that all fine because
he's a labor
politician well hang on a minute because
it's
i think this goes to the heart of the
matter if you're dealing with these very
complex issues
you have to have confidence in the
people who are leading you
and if those people who are leading you
are not open
and not honest do not are not prepared
to be accountable
that brings into question whether or not
they are competent and appropriate for
leading this country through these
difficult times
and it's not a question of you know of
boris john
if there's no such thing as a free lunch
sophie if somebody put
thousands of pounds into your bank
account
uh to pay for decorations if somebody
jets you over
to a caribbean holiday for free that
they will want something back there's a
favor they want back of it
and it's that issue it's not you know
that it's his personal money or that it
was party money
it's what are the favors that are wanted
back and if boris johnson doesn't come
clean
you're left suspicious that actually
it's impinging on his work as prime
minister
on the ppe contracts on who we are
points to
particular issues on how the greens hill
uh
scandal was dealt with on how he dyson
and his tax issues were issued were
there and is that the sort of britain we
want
do we want a britain you know britain we
i think we're in danger of
losing what i call our moral integrity
where
uh you know all all those standards in
public life
which are so important in maintaining a
strong
open uh sophisticated and developed
democracy
they're all threatened here and we can't
have confidence and trust
in our prime minister that's what i want
to prove if there's nothing in it
come clean and then we can move on but
at the moment he's refusing to do that
there's an allegation in the sunday
times today that the prime minister
asked a donor to pay for his
child care uh costs now number 10 has
said that the
promise had paid the cost they haven't
said whether or not he
paid the original bill or if he
reimbursed somebody else
now when i spoke to dominic rob he
dismissed this as gossip his title
tattle
what's your view well again
the worry with this and that's the other
reason that this issue is important is
is does this stand alone or is it the
tip of an iceberg
and are there other ways in which the
funding of his
rather lavish lifestyle has been
dependent
on individuals giving him cash and what
do they want in return of cash
there are two uh peers involved in this
both
lord brown brownlow and zach goldsmith
both of whom were put into the house of
lords zach goldsmith has got a position
now in government
uh we've got to come clean i do think
that's one of the worries is that
is the downing street an isolated
instance or are there are
other incidents like the allegations
around paying for the nanny
that could be there too and if that's
the case
if you're taking money in the secretive
private way how is it influencing how
you're approaching
the issues of state you can't go on like
that we can't have it
and it's not just me saying this i think
this is above party politics sophie
i think this really goes to the heart of
what we're about and there are a lot of
conservative commentators
from max hastings through who are as
concerned as i am
about the nature of the way in which we
are being governed today
this isn't this is a i think a really
dangerous point
in which our democracy could get very
undermined it's not just this it's
all sorts of things that happen you know
pushing aside parliament
uh sacking civil servants all these
uh you know not listening to the media
in the same way
not really caring about the rule of law
there are endless examples
where this administration led by boris
johnson
will not make maintain those standards
that are absolutely key for us being a
healthy democracy
we've got to attack key issues we
shouldn't be focusing on this
and we can't until we have confidence in
our prime minister
uh worth pointing out of course you know
we have approached lord brownlow for
an interview if zach goldsmith has got
any comment then we'd be very keen to
bring you that as well
um while i've got you i'm quite keen to
talk to you a little bit about the state
of the labour party
um because you know you're very
vehement about talking about the
failures of the current government but
at the same time
labour has struggled to find a lead in
the polls for many many months now
you've got the local elections at coming
up where you're looking like you could
even be losing seats like hartlepool
that's
always been labour why is it that you're
just failing to cut through
failing to cut through um i don't accept
that we're not cutting through
what you have to understand is the
general election in 2019
was the worst election result that
labour had uh experienced
since uh i can't remember 1930 i can't
remember the date but it's
decades and decades ago so we we've come
out of the worst position and
rebuilding trust with our voters
is something that will take time and i
think that's the first thing to say
if you look back at the tories in 1997
it took them time to rebuild it will
take us time coming out of that
appalling era
with jeremy corbyn as our leader it will
take his time to come back
and i think the second thing is this is
a very sort of
surreal time in politics we are all
concentrating
on the uh on the pandemic and
i think that sort of creates you know
parties and politics is something we all
want to come together as a nation
which is why forest johnson's position
and his integrity
is so absolutely crucial and almost
above politics
but i think in that time people are
concentrated on different issues
and i think that's a second a second
issue and the third one is we have to
now
rebuild a sense of hope uh in the future
and it's going to take us a bit of time
to uh reposition ourselves but i'm
actually i think kirsten has done
totally brilliantly
i did not voted for him in the in the
leadership election
but i've been very impressed by how he's
moved us forward
he's dealt with all the nasty elements
within the labour party
he's beginning to listen to people he's
starting to rebuild trust
and through a very difficult time when
he hasn't been able to sort of
be face to face with voters or do uh
big conference speeches i think he's not
doing badly i think he's doing rather
well
okay uh dave margaret hodge there thank
you for being on the program today